way back
[Music]
wow
[Music]
uh well
can i help you that is to say as a
matter of fact you can that's so
considerate of you to ask you see i was
over by the bar back there and i said
now there's a young man who could be of
great assistance accompanying me
back to my hotel well as much as that is
flattering
no no i'm simply a not a homosexual man
i'm in fact a
married man and so the dance begins
the two step where each of us cloaks our
true desires for fear of rejection
like a mystery ball the path to
unmasking one's truth is rife with
self-deceit
there's only one problem
i haven't a mask
and i'm too old to dance
oh come now you and i both know this act
is pointless a young man like you could
learn a thing or two from me having a
man like me show you the ropes why don't
we just skip this whole charade
stop wasting everyone's time as you
accompany me to my car well that seems
at the very least
mildly inappropriate for
lunchtime i've always loved the
barricade of age
unfortunately it's one of this world's
greatest ironies that those guarding the
most valuable treasures don't understand
their true worth
now now ben i of course misspoke when i
called you a boy obviously you're a
young man and i think it's one of this
country's greatest injustices
the strapping young lad like you just a
few mere years shy of a driver's license
can't so much as enjoy a simple beer
with his friends or
some of this earth's more fleshly
pleasures wait do you uh
do you think i'm a boy no of course not
you're a young man
no no i i mean i'm 35.
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
changes
[Music]
that's called a fake sip because it's
too hot
it's a little too hot and so i had to
fake sip it right there suppose a little
bit in the studio today do you notice it
doesn't stink it does stink a little bit
it does uh
yeah maximus maybe we need to we need to
get that checked out uh we have a lot to
get to today i'm glad to be with you uh
gosh
there's a theme today and it is largely
about not only the media a lot of people
tell you oh the media's liberal media's
corrupt sure yeah we get that
but
the idea that there can actually be
foreign influences who determine policy
and who determine
what you are allowed to say and not say
the forces that really have no interest
in the western world who are determining
what can be spoken in the western
hemisphere and in western journalism so
while they try and make you concerned
about elon musk purchasing twitter
there's a lot going on with people being
jailed in australia for speaking out
against human rights violations in china
there's a lot going on when you look at
what people at time magazine are doing
there's a lot going on when you look at
what disney is doing with a drag queen
children's show so that one i don't
really know i don't know how that
appeases the chinese i don't know i
think it's uh remember when kids would
just do the bozo show yes that was it
yes where he was grossly abusive to
cookie yes he was supposed to be
like hey kids here's cookie watch me
shove wood chips up his thumbs
i hate him
he's the reason i pay alimony
so
my question to you because i feel like
it's old hat just a question about media
i know how you'll answer is if you had
to go on a date with one democrat who
would it be who is it who you think is
evil but might be fun
i'll give you my answer in mug club okay
it's one that's going to appall you is
it aoc no no no no no no no no i've i've
learned you don't uh you don't do the
thing with crazy yeah yeah that's too
far that's the kind of stench that you
don't wash off no she's good from a
distance yes she'll boil the kid's pet
rabbit oh she certainly will but before
that hey look we have uh
gerald a is with she just had his new
baby yes last week i don't i don't think
we're supposed to show a picture of any
of that because we're not brian stelter
who uploads pictures of his children
without their consent
ad nauseum but we have gerald v in
studio how are you sir he's doing the
lamprey again yeah he's doing the
lamprey named his kid david it's a
perfect lamprey after his father
and uh you hear him you know him you
love him you can follow him at landau
dave and he is going to be this friday
in springfield missouri and then
saturday in lincoln nebraska he's made
it
louder with crowder.com tour for all the
dates we'll be announcing a major fall
tour soon uh dave linda how are you ahoy
good how about you sir i'm doing well
you had good time in green bay i did
they're good people down there yeah they
really are nice and yeah a lot of serial
killers come out of wisconsin it's true
and then i found out about more killers
that i won't mention on the show but i
googled the most disgusting thing i've
ever seen because the crowd was yelling
it out wow
i uh you can tell me on mug club yeah
yeah we don't want to talk about it here
no
you could get in trouble as opposed to
the drag queen uh generation drag and
distance oh that's fine yeah it's fine
yeah it's perfect have you watched you
know what let's just leave with this so
go ahead let's see the clip of discovery
plus unsatisfied with the raging success
of their documentary fauci
decided that they're going to debut a
new show now
called
okay
let me spoiler alert
everyone involved with this should be
arrested for child abuse the new show is
going to be called generation drag
which uh is going to follow five what
they refer to as drag kids or i refer to
as uh victims of parental abuse
um and and and the the the teaser is
just as horrifying as you might imagine
welcome
to the pink palace my lovely friends
i first discovered dragged at 13.
i didn't know what it was but i knew i
wanted it
put on the wig and the makeup and i'm
someone completely different i'm so
pretty
oh my god these are so [ __ ] cute
people are willing to pay and i'm a
trafficker
my name is noah and i'm transgender
so my mom started draguton kids and
their families are coming from all over
the country where we get to be our true
selves oh god and by true self i mean
dress like bratz dolls
this is a place of love and support
because we need that in this world
[Applause]
this is me and you better like it
well we don't but it's not an attack on
you it's an attack on your parents look
joe lewis turned away you guys look look
at this he turned away he's just trying
to go into the fire yes exactly like
this is another stick his head in that
chimney
i thought jimmy savile wish she was
still alive he's like you can just do
this on tv yeah i wouldn't have been
doing it behind closed doors think about
it this used to be a scandal
when you had people in hollywood right
where they were doing this with kids no
now it's just a show they pitched now
it's celebrated look
i truly believe that everyone involved
with this show should be arrested for
child abuse hey you're the director of
photography you're now a child
pornographer here are the forms that you
have to have all of your neighbors sign
for the rest of your life
i
why would you go to an arena field
there's no way there's not pedos there
judging it who judges it let me okay
here's another question of the day
the best the best comment uh will will
be pinned and you will live in infamy
forever is there anyone out there
genuinely anyone out there right now if
you are not a pedophile this question
applies to you
would you ever feel comfortable in the
audience there
anyone who's not a pedophile would you
feel comfortable watching children in
stripper garb somebody's commenting like
yeah why i mean why not yeah why not
just little kids dressing up as gayle
boys by the way this won't uh avail my
search history will it no i'm lying yeah
it's a wholesome family fun right yeah
it's wholesome family fun i used to
think it was child abuse to send a
six-year-old or eight-year-old or
ten-year-old girl to school with pants
that had juicy written across the ass
and now we're sending boys i got i had
to turn a big johnson shirt inside out
when i was in sixth grade yeah but this
is perfectly acceptable i just i uh and
then they say remember this is they're
just trying to trying to gaslight you in
florida they don't they just don't want
us to talk about our personal sexual
relationships look discovery plus is
disney we just said the disney i believe
ceo stepped down no idea if that was you
know
proactively trying to cut off the
pedophile train at the past but
the issue here is this is as bad
this is as bad as it gets it's as bad as
it gets you combine this with this is
what they want if completely unfettered
you already saw cuties at netflix they
told you they weren't coming for your
kids
when you brought that up they said you
were crazy they said you were paranoid
how much worse does it have to get i i
genuinely does it have to be actual
child pornography which by the way has
existed on youtube as well
i don't think it does i mean at this
point i guess i just don't understand
why if you're a boy going to your dad
and you're a child yeah a child you're
not like uh yeah we can't do this i
can't send you to a television show
where you can show everybody that you
dress pretty like a lady right i just
can't ima i i don't think you'd you know
it doesn't have to be
you cannot use my amazon prime account
to order a stripper pole right
i'm not saying that your dad should
chuck a beer bottle at you but it's
right i just it's enough your dad
shouldn't be you know uh instead of
playing house playing champagne room
no he should be
he did just he's like oh that's a good
son i just went to the bank and got a
bunch of singles yes let's have fun yeah
i'm going to call the friends over this
actually this isn't just disney now
discovery is owned by warner
oh is it it's spreading it's spreading
the warning like a pedophilic virus yeah
yeah
i'm sorry and these these kids are so
well yeah how do you do that with your
kid
you're just letting your son actually go
up there or you're i don't whatever well
they literally like kid unfettered
access to the internet since what they
were six yeah and that's what you get
well and i guarantee you right now if
you search
you know what right now do an experiment
search use you to use google search
child drag search uh generation drag and
see what pops up is it the overwhelming
response the sentiment that this is
grossly inappropriate
i don't know i haven't this is an
experiment right now in in real time i
would love to see what kind of results
you get this is the the the only silver
and i hate this i hate it it's like when
people used to say uh when donald trump
was running against hillary clinton you
would have some people say well i think
they're both two sides of the same coin
and so at least hillary clinton you know
will showcase the left for what they are
whereas donald trump will be enough of a
contrast yeah okay i get the silver
lining now with biden as well that
people see how bad it is but i wish that
we it didn't require this the silver
lining here is you do see the disconnect
between not just the media not just the
entertainment industry not just the
elites in washington dc but your public
school teachers i'm sorry true heroes
and the average american citizen
i can't even imagine that most you know
where are all the gay guys who just
wanted to get married saying they wanted
all the same rights right i thought that
you wanted to be domesticated white
picket fence have a dog come home plow
your boyfriend i thought that's what you
were looking for is this what you had in
mind generation drag because this is
coming from the lgbtq alphabet gestapo
community right now and i don't know how
far it goes i don't think that's
necessarily representative of the gay
community no it's not that's the problem
is they they try to sneak this under the
guise of them right they try to say like
oh well it's it's lesbian it's gay it's
trans it's whatever so now it's it's
kids in drag doing cartwheels in front
of you know
judges i guess well-adjusted adults yes
well-adjusted adults and judges that are
on skype from prison hey is there a
criminal was there a criminal background
check on every single judge there's no
possible way there's a criminal
background there's no way can you
imagine having the pedophile tracker on
your phone it's just a giant red dot in
that right now yeah the service gets
slowed down it's like oh these are peak
hours yeah they shut off my 5g i'm back
down to
to 3g because so many people using it
here it's like south by southwest only
with child rapists just everybody moving
from door to door of the local hotels
introducing themselves
yes going to be staying here all week i
know i'm also a monster what's your
son's name
to the concierge yeah oh yeah what do
you oh so you recommend that place
that's like a tapas where they have
different bites we could sample okay if
you could sign here just acknowledging
that we spoke
can you imagine if you're a pervert just
accidentally checking into that hotel
you're like i was just here on business
yeah i didn't know i was in heaven be
like tim curry in home alone too where
the light bulb pops off on the back of
his head bingo
okay i'm sorry is there a sting
operation going on this weekend i was
really open to catch some z's no no
there's no stinging operation uh those
who would conduct a sting operation like
the fbi cia they're too busy watching
generation drag yes they've actually
brought their kids here yeah yeah we've
seen subscriptions among three letter
agency members uh go up 900 percent yes
the release of this so
they're shooting abusive foster families
plus here yes yes
yeah uh tomorrow we'll be filming
relapse yeah it's
an exciting day for everyone who puts
makeup on their eight-year-old boy yes
and by the way just to be clear people
say oh it's just dress-up it's just
having fun no no there's a huge
difference and again they title it drag
drag has a historical connotation it's
not people copy pasting their fears to
it drag has been connected to
in a hyper sexualized part of the lg
back then it was just lgb community
since uh the early 20th century let me
read you a quote here f after the 1969
stonewall riots in new york city and
through the 1990s gay culture and gay
pride built mainstream support and with
that came popular drag culture has as
well it's always been linked to sexual
behavior it's always been linked to
sexual preference and these are kids who
really shouldn't i mean
i i would have a problem if a young girl
at that age wanted to be a stripper i
just like no no you can't go on stage
and undulate
well there was a problem with that in
new york where a kid wanted to do drag
shows and he i forgot what talk show he
was on but you i mean i'm sure you can
look it up but i mean be arrested but
there was a kid who is a couple of years
ago and he was like yeah i just was like
eight or nine or ten and he's like i
just i'm a drag kid and you know the dad
looked like clint howard just defeated
and the you know the munchausen wife is
like you go but you know you do it and i
i was like i wonder how long until he
gets molested it was like three weeks
after the show aired once upon a time if
it was like dr phil he would now now
you're dressing like a girl yeah all
right but you're actually a boy but now
he just has to support the mom and be
like no listen dad you have to let this
boy be who he is and you you need to
treat this woman like the queen she is
you can't hit her okay you have to and
everyone goes
all the daytime view women who happen to
tune in to dr phil yeah everything she
says is accurate you cannot put up a
fight now to be clear
okay you need to know that all women are
beautiful
in in every way
and you're a piece of [ __ ] okay because
you're a man raising your son to be a
man is disgraceful that is honestly i'm
disappointed i won't have a talk with
you in the green room after right
because you should not be you should not
be doing anything your wife doesn't like
okay we'll be right back all masculinity
is toxic your boy should not play sports
unless he is competing with other girls
yes thank you right okay that's all it
should i don't want to hear any more out
of you
to give you an idea of uh the crew that
put the show together so tara banks is
the lead executive producer but do you
mean do you mean the person who to
commemorate black history month redid a
photo shoot of herself as the first
black cover model of sports illustrated
she's like to honor black history month
i'm honoring me
so there there's she's the one that
chucked a phone at her assistant or is
that anyway
there's her and then there's jasmine
stodle and jasmine stodle's first uh
credit on imdb she was the set decorator
for a show called foursome a reality
show where four contestants two male and
two females stay in a huge house
together where they interact build
relationships and have hardcore sex oh
great
yeah that's a wonderful person to have
right for children that's great yeah
what channel was that on
[Laughter]
her it sounds to me like you're judging
her as a woman as a man with a penis all
right you're not supposed to have an
opinion
you don't know what they were doing in
that house they were having well they
were having sex but that's their
prerogative yeah they're just building
relationships and having foursomes you
should probably take notes because your
relation you know what i always say is
if you see a speck of sand in the
woman's eye you you're probably a piece
of [ __ ] as a man
this show's just simply called give it
to me caddy yeah they're all on the golf
course having foursomes me and steve
harvard get together to figure out how i
can bash men all right and he can bash
white people it works
it's our calling card all the greats
have their calling cards it's kids
family feud
what don't you want it's just one thing
it's penis yeah you think oh this white
boy said he don't want peter come on
everything white guys okay
[Laughter]
all right
now we move on to why i'm disgusted by
it okay and don't think for a second
that sometimes people get mad because we
have this is what's going on in the real
world okay christian conservatives this
show at least allows you i know a lot of
people have their church where everyone
speaks christianese and then they have
to go and watch netflix or watch
mainstream we're going to discuss the
things that are actually happening in
the real world and it's not to approve
of the degeneracy is to condemn it and
hopefully make this is the world your
kids are going into
you need to talk to your kids
you know you used to have to tell your
kids to not play with blasting gaps now
tell them
if it's a boy to avoid the uh to avoid
the uh to avoid the the strip the
stripper out to avoid going to uh adam
and eve shop
your boys shouldn't be shopping it used
to be don't play with blasting caps now
it's don't order from the fredericks
catalog and you're right people will be
mad because they want to try to make it
say okay look there's a there's
right-wing media saying that you should
attack trans kids and that's not true no
it's the company's saying you're saying
that you shouldn't hurt children right
simple stop going after kids right you
should milkshake their parents
absolutely
uh all right so now speaking of uh
people who are um incredibly ineffective
like those parents the white house
correspondents center took place i will
say this spoil alert trevor no this is
the first time i've ever seen him be
funny even accidentally so i wanna give
him credit where it's due he did it yeah
he did a good job he did go after both
sides of course that's because he
largely didn't write it right
um
but they kicked off the dinner by
playing a video montage and there are
some omissions which we'll get to in a
second that recapped previous white
house for those who don't know where
they kind of roast the president in a
very friendly way
previous white house correspondents
dinners here is how they led the night i
know there was some talk about uh minot
coming this year
and i admit the thought did cross my
mind
george always says he's delighted to
come to these press dinners
baloney
it is great to be here at the washington
hilton
is something a prostitute might say to a
congressman
isn't that what the confirmation process
is all about here in washington
weeding out the truly qualified to get
to the truly available
well here in one room we have members of
the media politicians corporate
executives advertisers lobbyists and
celebrities everything that is wrong
with america is here in this room
tonight
with that i just have two more
words to say
obama out
[Applause]
hey by the way one thing that there are
very few moments in history that are
more satisfying than watching back at
one of those correspondence dinners when
seth meyers and barack obama were
roasting donald trump as a joke yes for
uh losing his first bid as like in the
primary for republicans and he's just
sitting there just like okay
put it in the old memory chip
i think that's the moment he decided to
become president yeah it was like no no
i'm really going to go for it yeah it's
like when bruce wayne saw his parents
killed in the alley
[Laughter]
so here's the funny thing is they show
all of that and those are pretty general
but they did omit one of the most
legendary white house correspondents
dinners ever and that would be of course
norm mcdonald in the clinton years
where you can see here the audience did
not react the audience is largely press
so it's not the american audience so a
lot of people always wondered why norm
wouldn't do well at some of these events
and they'd be laughing at home was
because that audience isn't your
audience and he always had a he always
had a great sense for understanding the
people at home or who i'm
to whom i'm performing here's him at a
clinton white house correspondent i
believe it was 97 where the jokes fall
flat because they're far too true
anyways the dinner was great you enjoyed
the dinner we had some salmon yeah it
was delicious it was great and i thought
it was you know i thought it was
refreshing to see democrats serve
something other than subpoenas for a
change i thought that was nice you know
that we've had a president that has
hobbled you know and it's tough on
everybody the secret service is not easy
on the secret service they have had to
learn you know how to how to do this and
they've been specially trained on how to
lift and carry president clinton by top
experts who've been doing this for a
long time
boris yeltsin's secret service agents
they've
[Laughter]
there's a rumor that last week
a certain i don't want to say it is a
certain gentleman in abc news he went to
a party and he got really drunk and he
ended up having sex with his own wife i
don't know
how does that not land i don't care who
you are
it's probably just a vicious rumor
really
[Laughter]
i love that he's just enjoying the bomb
he's probably just a vicious rumor you
know that's seriously when he did what
was it that's what got him banned from
the view so yeah because he said that he
was on there he asked him about when
george w bush just won he said yeah you
know i think it's good getting uh you
know uh you know good man in the white
house you know getting murders out of
the white house yeah like what well
murder is out of the white house so i
don't know argue hey didn't you hear
bill clinton he killed a guy yeah
yeah he said i thought you were supposed
to be he didn't know that yeah
and he kept doubling down on it yeah
yeah joy bears like you can't just say
that he's like i'm not
yeah i'm not
i don't think i thought everyone knew
this and then he pulls out his cell
phone and he pulled out a cell phone
yeah hello huh and they go what are you
doing oh your producer told me before
it'd be funny if i pulled out and like
fake tucked in my phone on here so yeah
he was just just showcasing the absolute
the this house of cards that is the
entertainment industry uh all right so
going back to this saturday though
um here's biden and there's trevor noah
biden's reaction which is there's no
real winning with the reaction but
unfortunately in this case biden has to
laugh at uh the pain and suffering of
the american people so it just comes off
really poorly uh but i do think trevor
noah did a a better job than for example
stephen colbert or michelle uh michelle
wolf which which means in her native
tongue not funny
also a quick note before people order
their uber's home tonight governor greg
abbott is generously providing free
buses for the telemundo table
very classy very classy
i'll be honest i'll be honest i'll be
honest if you didn't come i totally
would have understood yeah yeah because
these people have been so hard on you
which i don't get i really don't you
know i think ever since you've come into
office things are really looking up you
know gas is up rent is up food is up
everything
no it really has been
a tough first year for you mr president
well surely you must be a little worried
about 2024 you know there's a lot of
passion on the republican side there
really is
you know it's going to be an interesting
time
thank you so much for having me
this is fun appreciate you
please be careful leaving tonight we all
know this administration doesn't handle
evacuations well goodnight everybody
thank you so much
that was funny it was funny that's fine
oh by the way speaking of evacuations if
we get evacuated from youtube you can
tune in every monday through thursday at
10 a.m eastern you can watch the free
show on rumble or you can watch of
course like the full
hour it's like an hour and a half to two
hours on mug club lighthouse credit.com
club uh cause youtube don't pay nothing
i think he did a pretty good job there
trevor noah i agree yeah i do i agree i
think uh it's sad because biden and
pelosi are like that where they go a
little bit too happy at the parts where
they're not supposed to right and that's
what he did i think he just didn't know
where he was yes i think you're right
because that was the moment where it's
like yeah food food prices are soaring
right gas is soaring and he's like i
know right
i did do that
people got started we were really hungry
like put an earpiece in him and just
like tell him like touch your forehead
you know if he has like like a uh you
know do that and then people won't hate
you the sad part is though even with the
earpiece it's like salute the salute the
marine he's like salute to the marine i
was like he would just be saying laugh
now like we've tried that there's no way
to work yeah but but you're supposed to
didn't say simon says
what
who told you we were going to do this
did simon say [ __ ] in my pants
yes it did yeah
can we just say that simon said it and
then you know oh have hi hang out say he
wasn't january 6 hang him out to dry
yeah also i need to dry my pants
i took 10 viagra last night nothing
not a wiggle yeah it turns out that was
adderall that's why it's struggling oh
it's yet i'm also weirdly unfocused yeah
i don't know how that works is it like a
biphasic effect where if you take too
much you you you get sleepy no not at
all you take more you get more sped up
you know hunter's wide awake and he's
got a jar of pez
uh all right uh let's it really does
smell in the studio which actually
brings us to our next story
she might be testifying today um amber
satan heard oh gorgeous woman
look
i mean that's not you're not being
facetious she is a beautiful physically
physically physically beautiful yes the
inside is i mean it's a test holiday
yeah oh it's no good no there's nothing
good about it no there's nothing good on
the inside um i mean if you know what
yellow ugliest woman on earth yes
exactly by the way they uh they had to
redact that film shallow hell now yes
the defensive to both fat people and uh
gwyneth paltrow yes
um
so johnny depp's this is she might
testify today and i think this is an
important story because it does it has
highlighted the the abuse that men often
endure which often goes uh completely
unreported and that's because men are
often afraid they're ashamed to bring it
forward and the physical abuse isn't
really as egregious as the emotional and
mental abuse that we've seen obviously
with amber heard i think regardless of
the defamation suit johnny depp has won
because she's probably done career-wise
no one will want to touch her he might
be rehabilitating his because we know
for sure that she physically abused him
we know for sure that she lied that she
was cheating on him that she didn't give
the money to charity that she's
dishonest
on every level
the only question is and we know that
johnny depp is a druggie weirdo okay
fine the only question now is did he
ever once retaliate physically and
there's no evidence of that think of the
standard that has applied to amber heard
and to johnny depp and i'll tell you
who's been most pissed off about this
when i've spoke is the women i've spoken
to
because they all know a woman like this
every woman i spoke to they go yeah i
would see that i would see that broad
coming a mile away i've seen guys get
torn up like this right well in
i mean when he started in film he went
out to hollywood to be a rock star yes
basically met nicholas cage went out and
uh
wes craven's daughter saw him and was
like oh he's hot so he got nightmare on
elm street so he's always been a bit of
a bad boy so being a druggie weirdo
wouldn't actually hurt his career at all
it's what made him is the fact that he's
a bit like that i think this has
actually revamped his career if anything
already yeah just by seeing it because
everything that he said has been proven
i mean he's right he's right yeah yeah
and as his closing statements were
really pretty impactful but to give an
idea as far as how far the abuse went uh
johnny depp security guard and i know
some of this can be hearsay but there
also are pictures i don't know if
they've done dna evidence on this
um
but they confirmed amber heard's the
event where she
pooped in johnny depp's bed and did you
have any discussions with miss heard on
the way to coachella that evening
we had a conversation pertaining to the
surprise she left in the boss's bed
prior to leaving the apartment and when
you refer to the surprise in the boss's
bed what are you referring to
the defecation
i love how's being trying to be such a
gentleman about it yeah is it what what
is what is that
oh no oh my god no it's oh
it's poo i have it too that's the thing
i have it too who did this seriously who
did this i have it too hold on a second
here it's who did this
who did this
are you serious
look at this
this is mug feces
this is mug [ __ ]
this isn't [ __ ] club oh
that's gross
this is disgusting seriously this is not
poop you know what i knew we had a
problem you know what the problem is
this is the problem in covering amber
hurt you know what the problem is yeah
you give her the press you create
copycats oh this is uh we know we need
to find out who did this and we need to
take care of it yes this is disgusting
you know what if it takes all week
so if you we'll find out we'll get to
the bottom of this all week
unbelievable all right right gerald b
right yeah
he's less affected he really doesn't
sometimes i i am jealous of his uh you
know sensory shortcomings i actually
think he drank his yeah well
that makes sense
at a certain point it does ferment and
you know liquor's liquor it does stink
over there so it does stink oh yeah it's
cultured yeast true i'm just making some
prison champagne hey
here's something else uh yeah some
toilet wine
it's this most disgusting thing we're
about to get to uh australia and free
speech in the united states mugs out of
here uh well i just put i just put them
over there okay i put it far enough to
us
i don't want it
i don't know that it's not one of you
yeah i'm
i'm keeping it just in case we have to
do a dna yeah i bet you johnny depp
wished that he had kept it yeah you know
in 23 and meet that stuff that's true
yeah yeah he could have and it just
comes back [ __ ] yep that's what it
would be
so uh
may day was uh uh yesterday
and for those who don't know um
in communist speak it's international
workers day
which is always funny to me i love how
there's no i want there to be because
this always means like employees i
always want there to be an international
you know small business owners day and
they just fire everybody
yeah because they always act like
business owners don't work
like you only work if you're in a union
or on a factory line
um so the holiday actually does have
surprisingly pagan roots but came to be
associated with the labor movement and
anti-capitalism which by the way i don't
know if you know about this helen keller
wrote about oh did you know that you
know the helen keller thing is complete
[ __ ] did you guys know this yeah
this is i know i'm going off on a
tangent today without gerald to try and
keep us on track did you know the helen
keller thing is complete horseshit do
you know the chances of someone who
can't hear
or uh see i think at two years of age
today learning how to it's a zero it's
never happened and helen keller was
doing this right and it was named anne
sullivan was it ann sullivan the lady
she was with helen keller didn't sign
helen keller would do this into her hand
she like and then she would go oh and
she is saying that we must support the
workers movement and destroy the
capitalist system you can read socialist
screeds and political endorsements from
helen keller that just so happened to
match her handler who was a charlatan
before that
to the letter
anyway yeah basically water burned her
hand and she screamed and she's like did
everybody hear that did everybody hear
that that's the big news she said we
need to uh
we need to uh try uh hoover for war
crimes yes
oh yes yes i do believe that we need uh
uh more uh taxation of the wealthy
yes that is the proletarius plight
yeah basically she went through life
feeling either pain or not yeah that was
it yeah and she couldn't communicate the
lies
so anyway yeah just touch my hand a
bunch anyway so we have may day right
now my point is uh yeah it's designed to
try and create class warfare and you
would think it was just about workers
rights if it was just about you know
representing people who are out there
working hard working nine to five you
know like alice coopers you and me one
of the greatest love ballads of all time
about a working man instead uh they
continued the pattern as they have
followed for the last several years of
destroying and burning down their own
cities here you go happy may
[Music]
[Applause]
day was 2021.
they are hard at work
yeah it's a good day
[Music]
they don't work for the bike store
[Applause]
[Music]
and now this is 2022 there's paris
wow
beautiful paris croissants anyone yep
that's a different ratatouille sequel
what an awful awful world yeah
i do love seeing them panic there yeah
they're like oh no consequences
jeez and then you scream how you didn't
do anything yeah
we just burned down paris yeah why are
you running at me right like when they
burn down a church
what is that
is that greta thuneberg is she being
intercepted by the aliens from signs
she's gurgling while doing it yeah
she's doing a ventriloquist routine yes
watch me
she turned 18 so her parents are
drowning her we have no use for you
we can't put you in any more child drag
shows
your old hat you're past your prime kid
your eggs are drying up
all right
so uh let's go to here australia
horrible place i'm sorry we have a lot
of people who follow from australia pogo
one of the best musicians around uh
australian and uh love them
but you know what when you start a
country as a penal colony for uh
murderers and rapists i guess it doesn't
surprise me that you end up with uh what
we have now
but i was hoping for better so
while campaigning and this is about free
speech you've heard me say this before
free speech doesn't exist outside of the
united states and people push back and
say yeah it does it exists
not in the way that it exists here in
the united states it's always curtailed
by well well i hate speech or offensive
speech and we've given you we've given
you some examples last week you can see
all the references at
lyderworthcrider.com and i want to get
to not just the danger of uh eliminating
freedom of speech for individuals right
we've talked about that with ourselves
for example on youtube on twitter by the
way i think we think it gains 180 000
followers in a couple days on twitter
just with that that little bit of
hitting the oh [ __ ] button removing the
shadow banning and we know it's far
worse on youtube so it does affect us we
also did some
number crunching on politicians and how
it would have affected elections of
course the most free and fair election
of all time but even then no one can
deny that if you look at the numbers
that uh if twitter and facebook and
youtube had not for example banned the
hunter biden story let alone shadow
banned uh conservatives from reaching
their own followers of course even under
the most free and fair conditions ever
the election would have gone the other
way every single other swing state we
know that statistically it's an
irrefutable fact so
let's stop worrying about russian bots
purchasing three thousand dollars worth
of uh i don't know tommy john ads on
facebook and uh let's start talking
about how this actually impacts you and
more importantly we just talked about
the child drag whatever the name of the
show is child drag dragnet
um drag kids yeah drake oh jeez your
camera just got moved by joe lewis yeah
he just if dave seems very out of focus
joe lewis just decided to hit dave's
camera joe you all right in uh in
australia here
please take drag kids off the air yes
[Laughter]
don't talk about it anymore we've ruined
it and amber herbs she's still she's
stealing my thunder but pooping that's
that's my job have your mug of poop are
you going to finish this yeah
[Laughter]
can i move that peanut i don't want the
peanut
get the epipen so
uh while campaigning uh on saturday uh
queensland senate uh uh someone who's
trying to send it i don't know you would
say hopeful elect
guy running for senate name is drew
pavlou
held up a sign that said in part of my
language if you have kids here i would
recommend that they leave because we
have to play these clips not only
because i want you to hear what they say
but it's also hilarious to hear chinese
people cussing english and you probably
have to get your kids to a drag show yes
exactly be late come on quick quick come
on there's gotta be
[Laughter]
so while campaigning uh senate hopeful
drew pavlou he held up a sign that said
[ __ ] xi jinping
and uh he was promptly berated and then
assaulted
by now this is bad enough but
the fallout is worse assaulted by
passers-by uh
for his troubles
just pull down his mask watch him run
away like a girl
[Laughter]
yeah that's true one move and you win
the fight
break the bands
now listen to what this last guy says
no no no words dictated
now i want to know something first off
did you hear what he said you are
violence because you are inciting now
this is the problem too is um for
example this even goes back to johnny
depp and amber really talk about abuse
talk about violence well okay it used to
be once upon a time that violence was
violence
then it became words or violence then it
became silence as violence then it
became jokes about jada pinkett smith uh
her alopecia is violence and warrants
this so this is now whatever they don't
like is considered violence whereas we
just counted three or four people there
who committed actual violence and by the
way violence
in the name
of a
dictator jinping who's committed
genocide right against i don't know
where the oppression olympics
where we stand right now with muslims i
guess if they're chinese muslims it
doesn't really matter because disney has
a new drag show to shell so i'm not sure
maybe another series of 10 adam sandler
films on netflix maybe no idea
but you would think here um
that uh those people would have been
jailed but no we'll get to that in a
second so uh pavlu uh
he described these people as chinese
ultra nationalists
that's how we described them now we are
going with limited information right now
so if something comes out that changes
i'm going by what we have
um
this guy who was just assaulted he rose
to prominence after uh he was assaulted
for calling out human rights but this is
what he's done human rights violations
and uh specifically from the chinese
communist regime
and uh as well as chinese influence in
australia which we've talked about here
in the united states media but this is
how this guy came to be popular i
sort of fell into this because i
organized one protest to support hong
kong and the uyghurs and um i was
assaulted on campus by chinese
nationalists and hundreds of chinese
nationals sort of descended upon us
after that happened the chinese consul
general in brisbane who was also made a
professor at my university
they have very close ties with the
chinese government
um
he endorsed the violence saying it was
patriotic my family received all these
death threats
um
and i kept on sort of protesting
eventually the university uh the
university of queensland and they have a
relationship with china worth 300
million dollars a year
they uh actually tried to expel me
so
that became this huge sort of uh i don't
know saga in australia
and
i'm still here you know
two almost two and a half years since
the first punch where i got punched um
still kicking and um now we're running
for parliament
so a couple of things here don't you
also find it funny that the you know you
see the left we're talking about oh this
guy is a racist um how these are the
same people who were starting campaigns
against like gap for sweatshops of
course but when the actual communist
chinese government
is committing genocide and is abusing
their own people they
john cena come out and apologize oh of
course
and by the way
uh
no you don't you hate the chinese people
i would say you hate the chinese people
because you're appeasing the government
that oppresses them
the government who jails them if they
have the
bible
and you have enough money to say no yes
and you're still choosing yes that's a
good point
it's it's great that you see sick kids
in the hospital and that kind of thing
it's great john cena but this is wrong
and you know it yeah also stop dealing
steroids to kids in the hospital it
doesn't help them and the st jude's kids
don't need nandra alone yeah fast
furious nine is not worth your soul
right
anything with nine on the end it also
crushes the soul of anyone who watches
it so you would expect the chinese
nationalists uh which also is another
example of hey just like i said money is
amoral firearms are amoral you can use
money to uh buy drugs or you can use
money to help people in need right you
can use a gun to rape someone at
gunpoint or you can use a gun to kill
the rapist trying to rape somebody at
gunpoint the same thing with patriotism
patriotism is a moral depends on
to what it is you're patriotic
patriotism so certainly the idea of the
united states the idea of life liberty
pursuit of happiness justice for all you
know the country that fought one of the
bloodiest wars of all time to end
slavery that still goes on in africa in
the middle east that's great patriotism
meaning allegiance to a government that
kills minorities
and silences its citizens and forcefully
aborts young girls
that's bad patriotism in itself is not
bad nationalism in and of itself is not
bad
it's to which nation are you pledging
allegiance so you would think that the
chinese nationalists who you know you
saw on camera believe you're lion eyes
who committed assault they would be
facing charges turns out
uh according to pavlu again what we have
right now i have no reason to believe
that uh he's being dishonest that it's
actually him facing
the criminal charges
uh from the police there in new south
wales he this is what he tweeted new
south wales police just called to tell
me i'm getting charged for holding up a
sign saying [ __ ] xi jinping in sydney
they won't tell me what the exact charge
is and they won't tell me whether the
men who physically assaulted me are
being charged uh and this is par for the
course of course uh with uh you know
commonwealth countries that include free
speech let me give you some other
examples uh of of places like this um
zoe lee bueller was an australian who
was arrested for posting about an
anti-lockdown protest on facebook
arrested you still believe that uh
it's just about a private business we've
talked about the ministry of truth when
people say facebook twitter they can do
whatever they want what about when they
appease governments who arrest their
people for writing things in the digital
town square
is it no longer a first amendment issue
where's the liability there oh they
don't have liability because we've given
them section 230 protections do you see
what a tide ball of it's like it's like
the christmas lights when you pull them
out from the for the winter we've got to
untie this government is in an unholy
alliance with big tech the uk of course
remember count dankula was convicted of
a hate crime for teaching his pug to
nazi salute which is still hysterical in
new zealand
the freedom convoy protesters they were
arrested for uh protesting coveted
restrictions
that i taught joe lewis to goose step
yeah it's fine okay he does it naturally
oh good yeah he's that's when he's
dragging his ass across the carpet
you didn't have to put the you didn't
have to put the swastika armband on him
though well i had already had it yeah i
know he wasn't custom-made or anything
for them i just took it off mine
my other dogs the united states is the
only place with freedom of speech and
when i try and tell you this a lot of
people on the left say this is
fear-mongering no you can look to any
other country you can look to my home
country of canada right our good friend
mike ward was put before a human rights
tribunal for a joke 40 grand talk about
the truckers who had their accounts
frozen
accounts frozen who by the way
uh was it paypal what was the uh was it
gofundme pay i don't remember it was
gofundme paypal with us we run into
paypal shopify decided to freeze their
funds because of their political
persuasion are you still saying oh just
a private business they can do whatever
they want what about when they're taking
marching orders from the government and
doing so selectively are these laws
being applied equally so i want you to
know when you're when you're watching
out there the left is constantly trying
to gaslight you and say oh you're just
trying to cry victim no no people's
lives are being arrested they're being
criminally criminally charged in other
countries outside the united states
simply for speaking an opinion that the
government has deems to be unpopular and
that's what the left wants here in the
united states they don't have it yet
though so when you have these rand
random
these random charts and these graphs
that rank the united states below places
like australia
on freedom of speech you know they're
full of [ __ ] just like when they rank
cuba above the united states in
healthcare
this is the problem with globalism they
don't apply the same standard you really
think that that australia that canada
are more free than the united states
can i interest you in a time share
[Laughter]
in the ministry of truth thing here in
the united states i forget the actual
name because we should just call it
ministry of truth that's as scary as
anything that has taken place in my
lifetime that is a line in the sand yeah
that's a line in the sand
i think it should be for everybody
especially when you see what's happening
in australia and new zealand and canada
and the uk so what's basically happening
though is let's put this in context the
police in australia the police
they're running they're running defense
for a foreign regime a communist regime
in a way that is antithetical to what we
believe here in uh in the west and
here's the thing you have police running
defense for that regime
but then you also have media the
entertainment industry running defense
for that regime you have disney you have
marvel right universal is fast and
furious nine we had that john cena clip
that we just showed you these uh
entities
that exist and you're talking about five
companies really that run all of media
and about five companies that run all of
big tech have a vested interest
in securing
the the political future
of those in power in china right now
this is not a conspiracy i mean just
look what happened with kovid for crying
out loud one of the chinese ambassadors
accused the united states military of
creating kovit and that didn't get
removed
you're concerned about elon musk posting
his opinions on wellbutrin right
after
it is astonishing to me also yeah after
two years of lockdowns howard it's like
okay that's over yeah no one's bothered
you've got to be
yeah i i think a lot of people are
bothered because they are but they're
afraid nobody can do anything like
that's you're right though that just
shows the freedom of america versus
everywhere else and and again the
question is not what has the left been
able to do
the question is what would they do if
they had so so look what they did
complete unfettered power look at
when aoc was she tweeted can we find
this actually so i can bring it back up
later aoc tweeted to uh
gosh i think it was i don't know if it
was elon musk or someone she said you
know uh the example of the the right she
said show me something this extreme on
the l that's been implemented on the
left legislatively
i don't remember exactly what it was but
it was a tweet and i i tweeted her about
this like oh okay that extreme how about
how about abortion up until and
including birth period uh taxpayer
funded i would say that's extreme how
about your five-page bill that takes
over a fifth of the united states con
economy the green new deal just because
it was blocked by people with
that the rational component of their
brain that hasn't been damaged doesn't
mean that you didn't want it
that's what's scary
what's scary is when you look to to beto
o'rourke pointing to australia as a good
example for gun control that's a ban
when you look at people pointing to
trudeau pointing to the uk as good
examples of what we need to be doing
here in the united states regarding
social media that means that social
media will help report people
espousing opinions against the
government and they can be arrested by
the way the ministry of truth it's under
the department of homeland security
which means they have an enforcement arm
means they can arrest you
it's not just it's not just like a you
know whitehouse.gov petition
they want what is happening here and
think of how this guy is running for
office in australia
and part of his platform is speaking out
against foreign influence in their
country foreign influence by the way in
their elections and if you bring up
collage g of course we have foreign
influence uh in our elections as far as
our own former vice president has vested
interest in chinese money as well um if
you speak out against that yeah well
yeah there's only tons of proof of it on
a laptop right and if you speak out
against it you might have
a bureau of the government with the
ability to enforce it through arrest
work hand-in-hand with social media to
get rid of you
and they've said that's what they want
they've been open about it i don't know
how many clips we have to show you when
jen sackey says we want to see more of
this when joe biden says we want to
remove more misinformation when people
wanna they're freaking out about elon
musk right now on twitter we'll get to
that in a second what about this
this isn't what about ism just can you
talk about this at all
well aoc parks in a handicapped spot so
she can run into whole foods and get a
coconut to eat like an apple with her
stupid horse teeth yes drinking it
through a cardboard straw yeah there's
that aoc tweet by the way which the
extreme left is taking over where
because someone tweeted out that the
extreme left is taking over the the
liberal party should where in texas
republicans passed a law allowing
rapists to sue their victims for getting
an abortion no they didn't can anyone
name a far-left policy that extreme that
extreme implemented anywhere we can't
even get our party to import cheaper
rx's from canada foh she wrote
is that what does that mean foh faux
i don't know she wants some vietnamese
soup and she doesn't know how to spell
it there should be a good uh this big
courtroom tv show that comes on right
after drag kids yeah yeah
exactly uh i think abortion up until and
including birth which governor ralph
northam admitted in virginia i think
that's as extreme and i think what aoc
has proposed is as extreme she's trying
to say where it's been implemented
because the left sucks at implementing a
lot of these things how about the laws
that you want to propose of children
being allowed to be on puberty blockers
i think that that's pretty extreme
it means f out of here
f out of here
f o h yeah shouldn't it be in caps
well that's distinguished of apology yes
exactly i don't and you know what
bartender i think she i think she meant
to write like like lol or dough but she
couldn't she isn't it a death perception
yeah oh she's like huh what do i what do
i type i'm doing my best i don't
understand my eyes go everywhere but
straight all i'm saying is that uh and i
don't know anything about the sky drew's
political stances
i do support uh at least his stance uh
in saying uh
[ __ ] xi jinping yeah he's right
donald trump don't trust china china is
[ __ ]
all right joe lewis that's enough hey
you know what someone come grab joe
lewis you might have to go to the
bathroom after watching the dragnet
magnum child drag
i had to pet him whenever he comes to me
i can't help it miami drag it's just
miami drag all right so now let's move
on to uh to uh it's terrible what's
happening here in the united states by
the way smash that like button as you're
watching uh smash and uh send a
congratulations to g morgan in the
comment section there yes
um awesome let's get to how the media
here because thank god we have checks
and balances where the united states
government can't do exactly what they're
doing in australia so
who's doing the hatchet work well
that's the media that's legacy media
just like when cnn went after us and
again they use a non-profit they
legitimize it through a media outlet
then social media gives it the right of
way to turn it into a trend i've told
you that's the mo those three steps
every time that's how they try to cancel
somebody okay
well right now what they're doing with
elon musk is uh
first off i mean there's a lot to do but
they're using this red herring fallacy
so here's what time magazine
and this is how lazy legacy you deserve
to die time magazine i mean you deserve
to die as a publication figuratively
it's time
to die yeah hitler was but elon musk i
believe was times man of the year last
year if i'm not mistaken oh and now
they're now he's the devil yeah because
last year they were saying buy his cars
oh so the electric car thing's good but
him owning a platform bad correct
because he moved to texas
ah right so here's what they were
writing about in time magazine they were
writing that elon musk could have solved
so many problems instead of buying
twitter they said elon musk could have
solved america's homeless problem he
could have solved world hunger he could
have educated every child in nearly 50
countries okay before we get to why
that's not correct this is what we call
the red herring fallacy it's a logical
fallacy let me read you the definition
of that it's diverting attention from
the real issue by focusing instead on an
issue having only a surface relevance to
the first so elon musk is purchasing
twitter right
this deal is very likely going through
of course and uh people are happy about
it he said that he will follow the law
and he won't go beyond the law in
censoring speech that is having the left
freaking out why because they just know
there's going to be an even playing
field they're not even complaining about
conservatives being favored they're just
complaining about conservatives or
right-leaning people being allowed on
the platform so instead they try to say
uh you know what uh why isn't he doing
this with his money well first off it's
none of your business and secondly it's
irrelevant
well it's his money and also why if you
want to be concerned about what he does
with his money why don't you be
concerned about what happens with your
money that's a good point and i'm going
to bring that up in a second because i
have some wealthy people there who own
the media conglomerates that are in
charge of time magazine so these are
lofty goals and this is another problem
with the left is they believe that oh
there's x amount of money if you throw x
amount of money in a problem it it just
it fixes it for example if you have a
stupid child then you just spend as much
money as humanly possible to send them
to schooling or trade yeah or or drag
school it's like clown college just drag
college yeah
they said there's more makeup yeah it's
a dual clown drag college yes the
makeup's the same yeah silly shoes so
they
they believe if you throw money at it
it'll fix the problem uh and therefore
it's our right to say that elon musk
should use that money okay well here's
the thing if you were to actually
confiscate all the wealth from
billionaires here in the united states
all of it all of it it wouldn't fund the
united states federal government for one
year
in 2020 the combined wealth of 745
billionaires was about 5 trillion
dollars a federal budget was about 6.82
trillion dollars that's not even
including the american rescue plan which
i don't i forgot how many trillions we
ended up with
[Laughter]
that means that if you confiscated all
the wealth you could fund the government
for approximately 263 days how is that
money going to educate every child
across all 50 states it's
gonna be hard just the 43 billion that's
not even i mean that wouldn't even show
up as a percentage we could teach most
of them the alphabet yeah
yeah half quarter gonna be a for all
whites are racist b4 black lives matter
c for aoc
yeah
well they're solutions b4
yes no yes give elon musk money to the
government that'll solve the problem and
it's funny how no one at time again so
this is what they do they go elon musk
buying twitter let's focus on what he
should do instead of that again none of
your business but it's funny how no one
at time is making that same argument
about the magazine's owner the guy is
mark benioff he's worth 7.8 billion
dollars but still gets his haircut at
sports clips
[Laughter]
that's a guy who looks like he enjoys
his money too much yeah he looks like he
just fell asleep on a yacht completely
drunk can you not part hey can you not
part ways with with uh i don't know
three billion it's none of my business
you do what you want but three billion
how about how about four billion how
much can you part with to solve world
hunger 1 million yeah it's a million i'm
at 100 million
hey you at home hey writers at time
magazine or people who work at big tech
most you make six figure incomes do you
really need that six figure income if
all of you pulled together
you could you could have hundreds of
millions of dollars right now that you
could put into the institution of your
choice what about oh what's the what's
the number crossover where you get to
determine that someone else should give
their money and how much money is that
this and by the way do you have the
metrics do you have the data to show us
exactly how elon's whatever is it 42
billion 43 billion somewhere between 40
and 45 billion for twitter do you have
the metrics that show us exactly how
that would quote solve world hunger it's
only 43 billion someone get bono on the
phone i know well that guy does look
like he has fed a lot of the children of
jamaican prostitutes yes so i'm just
saying we cannot confirm or deny that
fact you know we can't confirm or deny
we're not snopes no not at all it's a
maybe so this is why they do it's a
probably it's the red herring fallacy
and i want to focus on those more as we
go forward the logical fallacies that
are often presented especially running
into it changed my mind i want you to be
prepared for these because you should be
learning about these in college but they
actually don't teach you this in college
because they don't want you to recognize
what the professors are actually doing
did you know elon musk could put
everybody through college in america
instead of buying twitter
yeah he could yeah he could have done
that he could have done that yeah and uh
um and then
thank god he didn't yeah i'm just
telling you
so
everyone should know that yeah
i learned that in college yep yep no i
know i know i learned stuff in college
too that's entirely wrong yeah
[Laughter]
so the reason that they do this is
because what it really is about and they
don't want to tell you this is they just
want to control speech online as you see
in australia in the uk in canada where
you can be jailed for things that you
say online and they don't like that elon
musk is moving the ball in the other
direction just listen to cnn contributor
david zurarik
say this he said this yesterday no i
think there's a bigger problem that when
we focus on the personalities of people
like elon musk and people say oh i think
elon's thinking this or that
there's a bigger problem here about how
we are going to control the channels of
communication in this country in 1927 we
had the radio act 1934 the
communications act
congress stepped in we made rules fcc
wasn't great but it's still regulating
the broadcast industry you can't use
vulgar language you can't do all these
things with speech this is dangerous we
can't think i wish he had hair so i
could swirl him but no i'm serious we
don't have people in the comments
that can make it work i think we can
look to the western countries in europe
for how they are trying
but you need
you need controls on this you need
regulation you cannot let these guys
control discourse in this country or we
are headed to hell are you talking about
jeff bezos are you talking about
citizens just care are you talking about
mark zuckerberg
so you're saying by control also you're
saying freedom yeah he's saying you
can't allow them to allow freedom that's
what you're saying yeah that's exactly
what he's saying and we in in case you
were wondering wait is he really saying
that we should have less freedom then he
says let's look to the countries like
you have in western europe where they
have less freedom where people can be
jailed for what they say again what
would happen in this country if the left
had what they wanted completely
unfettered keep in mind this is the same
liberal media who would have had you
believe uh that malcolm nance was out
there and remember his war fighting
cosplay in case case you don't remember
this
with the context
he never went out into war uh but he
wanted so it's hilarious now when you
watch it when you first watched it you
thought he was brave
now you realize it's a fisher-price gun
yeah
well he claimed that he was out in the
front lines of the ukraine with joy reid
here you go you know as the more i saw
of the war going on the more i thought
i'm done talking all right it's time to
take action here so uh about a month ago
i joined the international doesn't have
panels uh legion has appearing it's a
double chin strategy and i am here to
help this country
fight you know what essentially is a
mouthful with a mother of its of
extermination
yeah now oh wait hold on a second wait
wait no wait wait are you wearing pajama
pants yeah yeah i'm out here in the in
the bush i just made an ear necklace
did you wait did you think he was a
soldier that he kind of implied that uh
well i mean he you know he meant he was
a cnn he meant he was sorry he was a
news contributor oh msnbc contributor
well you're allowed to wear what you
want yeah no exactly just because you're
dressed up like a [ __ ] doesn't mean that
you're easy no of course not just
because you're dressed like a soldier
holding a gun doesn't mean that you're
in the military no exactly
so the shame on you
shame on you for making
the you're making a leap a logical leap
that you see him saying he's in the
front lines of the ukraine and that it
was time to stop talking it was time to
start acting and he's standing there
with his gun and exam you made a leap
shape on you for thinking that he also
he said that he was out there in the
front line so shame on you for thinking
that he was actually doing that because
then in an interview with the guardian
nance said that he was uh so important
they had to keep him safe so he said no
matter where i am no matter what i'm
doing i'm constantly checking my gear if
i'm in a safe house or on a press junket
like i am now i go over all my gear
right now part of my duty is to the
press and by that he meant all of his
duty they were well aware that i was a
high level asset so instead of putting
me out in the line i'm in a safe house
talking to people like you hey hold on a
second hold on a second can we play that
clip again i'm in a safe house talking
to people like you but you just said the
time for talking was over let's start
playing it again you know as the more i
saw of the war going on i thought [ __ ]
i'm done talking all right pause it's
time to take pause
quote i'm in a safe house talking to
people like you let's rewind that clip
again as though we're in a courtroom i'm
in a safe house talking to people like
you instead of being on the front lines
let's play the clip again as the more i
saw of the war going on the more i
thought i'm done talking okay so look
it's pause you can just get rid of it
it's the shame on you for thinking that
he was done talking when in fact quote
i'm in a safe house talking to people
like you what did you think he was doing
what he told you
by the way what war was going on in
upstate new york at the time where is he
standing well you know the the jets and
the sharks have moved to albany
i'm in the woods behind my house
so this uh and we're going to play what
the flag on mug club here in just a just
a few minutes because there's no way we
could play it on youtube and the
ministry of truth would get to us but
look the same media right now at time
who's trying to say why isn't elon musk
doing this why isn't elon musk solving
world hunger this is the same media who
says we need to control what happens
online and we need to make sure that
misinformation is removed and we need to
make sure that we look to countries like
western europe or we look to countries
like they've actually pointed to
australia where people are being
arrested or places like canada where
people are being arrested and protests
are being shut down and accounts are
being frozen and that's what the media
is absolutely begging for here while
simultaneously
as you just saw all references available
a lot of credit.com
lying about
everything and here's when you know
someone's a compulsive liar
and i'll leave you with this
this guy's name what's that guy's name
again nance malcolm nance malcolm nance
so malcolm nance is a compulsive liar
let me explain i had a kid who i knew in
high school who was your impulsive liar
is there proof that he's a liar
yeah we just what he just said and then
he said the opposite oh right but i
don't know which one is the lie oh the
military thing right okay basically
anything that's impressive is probably
the lie you're right
[Laughter]
so i knew a compulsive liar in high
school
and he would avail lies to you
that we're not required we're
unacquainted lies you weren't you didn't
ask him something like catch him on the
spot like does this dress make me look
like everyone lies sometimes like no
yeah that just makes you look great well
you have to the world would right the
world
would burn
but
when someone lies
for no reason then there's no gain other
than the game they falsely create
through the lie in other words nance
there okay nance was a reporter at a
shitty network okay
so we all assumed he was doing shitty
reporting for a shitty network but then
he doubled down no exactly none of us
would have cared if he just said hey i'm
here in ukraine doing a shitty job like
well that's what nance does
we don't care none of us it wouldn't
have been a story it's only when he
decides i know what will get them i'll
lie and go out in full battle regalia
and tell them that the time for talk is
over and that i am going to the front
lines while i'm not there's really no
reason to create that lie other than for
self-aggrandizement now here's the thing
that's one reporter and that's funny but
when you take into account that that's
most reporters not only brian williams
not only dan rather but the people who
work in the reporting rooms the same
people who want to lie when they're a
story like for example a lie that they
just made up about donald trump and
russian prostitutes when you take into
account the totality of people like
nance
you realize that you do have a media
that is run by compulsive liars
and the government is saying hey we need
to look to them to be our consultants we
need to look to them to be the advisors
on this ministry of truth and by the way
what's our stated goal to be more like
europe where there's less freedom no
this is your line in the sand i think
we're better than europe that's why we
left and right now we're going to leave
youtube hit the like button you can
leave a comment we're going to go to
play what the flag on mug club which is
about new gender flags it's
it's grossly offensive for the youtube
audience namely because it involves a
mime which uh there's a special place in
hell for those people it really is
piss off
[Music]